depuis des milliers d'années les
activités agricoles fabrique des
paysages souvent d'une grande beauté
cette beauté là on la ressent on la
recherche aussi on est même prêt à payer
plus pour une maison avec une jolie vue
en campagne par exemple
mais si certains pays d'europe valoriser
même finances l'entretien des beaux
paysages agricoles
ici au québec on a encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire il ya des territoires au
québec qui se développe très rapidement
un peu n'importe comment
c'est que le territoire est souvent
laissé en pâture un pur acte à qui le
possède
il ya une question d'harmonisation une
question de qualité de vie
le paysage est un bien collectif
[Musique]
si ce paysage est beau aussi les gens du
plaisir de venir chez nous c'est grâce
aux paysans qui n'ont forgé ce paysage
[Musique]
le paysage chez nous qu'ils façonnent
une façon pour nos pratiques nos achats
nos déplacements et donc ce n'est que le
reflet de nos mains
[Musique]
c'est assurément un des très beaux
chemins au québec depuis de nombreuses
décennies
gerald de dôme on étudie l'évolution du
paysage et du territoire au québec on
voit avec la topographie ça aide
beaucoup d'avoir un accès visuel hudak
et comme c'était très cultivé à l'époque
mais percée visuelle était très très
nombreuses et très variée mais bon ça
change et la fraîcheur repris la forêt
repris il ya des nouveaux arrivants qui
sont implantés qui pourraient voir leur
calme
on me les clôtures ont mis des haies
brise vent ont mis des haies de cèdres
tous est fermé donc c'est un peu
l'histoire de 0,7 à peu l'histoire se
traduire par une évolution de
l'agriculture et la perte de certains
paysages que l'agriculture a façonné au
québec comme partout l'agriculture
fabrique les paysages fabrique ce que
l'on voit
mais quand l'agriculture change le
paysage change lui aussi jusque dans les
moindres détails
[ __ ] juste un exemple et les clôtures
oui plus que tu l'aies plus de culture
alors qu'auparavant des cultures de
perdre est partout
ce paysage le il restait agricole mais
il n'a rien à voir avec paysages que
vous alliez rencontrer dans les années
40-50 même 60
comprendre l'évolution d'un territoire
c'est comprendre un jeu complexe un
rapport de force très très complexes
entre eux les conditions naturelles donc
le climat
le relief qui plus ou moins adaptés à
différents types d'agricultures les
types de sols nos politiques agricoles
et jusqu'à aujourd'hui l'évolution des
marchés mondiaux aussi qu'ils vont jouer
sur la pelouse de nos territoires
au québec on repère deux grandes phases
de transformation du territoire agricole
la première elle va s'étendre vers les
50 jusqu'aux années 80 puis la deuxième
des années 80 à aujourd'hui
[Musique]
en 1950 environ le quart de la
population québécoise vit de
l'agriculture la production laitière et
rennes en 1950 on estime qu'à peu près
60 70 % des fermes sont des fermes
laitières
les vaches sont à l'extérieur en
pâturages et les fermes ont plusieurs
bâtiments y avait beaucoup de bâtiments
qui travaillent très rapprochés et qui
donnait chacun sur une surface
rectangulaire qui est cultivé et donc
que les chante beaucoup d'outils
l'épaule et pop et est beaucoup plus
petit à cette époque le territoire
agricole occupe une large part des zones
habitées que ce soit dans les basses
terres du saint laurent comme en
montérégie déjà fortement agricole ou
dans les régions périphériques dans les
plateaux laurentides hien ou appalachien
là on a une agriculture qui a une
génération qui dira juste de défricheur
territoire c'est quand même des
territoires qui sont très difficiles à
cultiver pour va avec ça on va nourrir
la famille tout cela va changer et très
rapidement durant les décennies 60 70
alors que l'agriculture se modernise
s'industrialise la productivité agricole
et la taille des fermes augmente mais le
nombre de fermes diminue entre 1950 et
1980 on perd à peu près 7,9 ferme par
jour au québec
chaque jour qui passe 7.9 fermes
disparaissent
parallèlement l'étalement urbain prend
de l'ampleur les meilleures terres
agricoles sont menacés et pression
urbaine était telle qu'on voyait en fait
les meilleures terres agricoles du
québec notamment autour de montréal
disparaître sur l'urbanisation avec
d'excellents terres qui étaient en
friche sous spéculation conscient qu'on
attendait de pouvoir développer ces
territoires ya quatre ans pour
s'attaquer à ce problème le gouvernement
du québec vote en 1978 la loi sur la
protection du territoire agricole pour
les gaspiller détruire à la même époque
les gouvernements fédéral et provincial
met en place la gestion de l'offre des
politiques de stabilisation du revenu
ainsi que l'assurance récolte
ce sont des mesures qui auront aussi un
effet sur le territoire agricole si
entre 1950 et 1980 on a perdu beaucoup
de territoires agricoles
nos pertes de territoires agricoles
elles font beaucoup plus faible à partir
des années 80 donc nos politiques
agricoles elles ont quand même permis de
stabiliser et de réduire ses pertes de
territoire agricole
depuis les années 80 le territoire
agricole dans les basses terres du saint
laurent s'est maintenue et ce malgré les
pressions du développement urbain mais
le paysage agricole de ces régions a
changé avec la chute du nombre de fermes
il y a moins de bâtiments dans le
paysage la modernisation des techniques
de production fait aussi entrer les
animaux dans les bâtiments fini les
beaux pâturages et les fermes qui
restent sont désormais grosse avec des
parcelles plus grande en 1967 on avait
cinquante cinq mille ferme et fière
aujourd'hui un récent environ 5000 dont
ça vous donne une idée de la vitesse de
transformation et de la concentration
l'industrie porcine connaît elle aussi
un boom de développement modifiant du
coup paysage et culture en montérégie
par exemple dans les années 50 ces
grands champs étaient occupés à 60 70 %
par la production de fourrage
aujourd'hui sur ces même superficie le
maïs grain et le soya ont remplacé les
cultures du foie dans les régions en
périphérie des basses terres du saint
laurent
la disparition des fermes et du
territoire agricole est préoccupante
on est dans un paysage qui s'est
extrêmement transformé au cours des 60
80 dernières années
on parle ici d'un paysage qui était à
peu près à 60% cultivées dans les années
aujourd'hui doit rester à peu près 10%
d'agriculture nous disent qu'ils avaient
à l'époque il ya un resserrement de
l'agriculture une montée de la friche
donc c'est sûr que quand les fraîchement
ben on risque d'avoir moins d'attrait au
risque de perdre sa place et
particularités ont pu risque de perdre
son attractivité
[Musique]
depuis les dernières décennies au québec
la loi sur la protection du territoire
agricole a permis de protéger des
superficies pour l'agriculture mais on
n'a pas protégé l'agriculture comme
activité sur ces territoires
dans beaucoup de régions quand on parle
du développement on parle du
développement urbain du développement
d'autres activités économiques que
l'agriculture ce territoire agricole
ça va être vu comme un espace à
développer et non pas un espace à
protéger et à développer pour
l'agriculture donc il ya aussi tout ce
rapport là et cette redécouverte de
l'agriculture qu'il faut faire aussi sur
nos territoires
ce que vit le québec n'est pas unique la
modernisation et la mondialisation de
l'agriculture ainsi que l'urbanisation
ont modifié notre territoire et nos
paysages et cela risque de s'accélérer
dans les années à venir
le paysage est le reflet de nos
politiques de nos relations au
territoire et c'est simplement
l'expression
si une accentuation une intensification
des usages le paysage se transforme
si demain matin en sommant importer du
lait c'est sûr que si on change quelque
chose d'aussi important que les coteaux
les tisser succès une répercussion
immédiate et très très fort sur le
paysage
il faut je pense se faire à l'idée que
ça va évoluer comme ça toujours évolué
la question s'est il compose ce jour
c'est vers quoi on veut que ça évolue
[Musique]